foreign
let's get uh started
um welcome everyone uh to Simon's
Institute and this Workshop uh my name
is venkat guruswami and I'm a senior
scientist here at the Simon's Institute
for the theory of computing and it's my
great pleasure to welcome you to The
Institute and this week's Workshop
as all of you I'm sure no the Simon's
Institute is the leading international
venue for collaborative research on
theoretical computer science it was
established in 2012 uh with a generous
Grant from the Simon's Foundation which
continues to support us very generously
now and The Institute brings together
the world's leading researchers in the
theory of computing and related fields
as well as the next generation of
outstanding Young Scholars this is the
10th year of programs at the Simons
Institute and we're really proud as a
community of the achievements of the
wide-ranging programs which have pushed
the frontiers of TCS in many directions
making progress on long-standing
challenges of the field as well as
opening up new directions of inquiry
so each semester the Simons Institute
hosts two Central programs that attract
several long-term visitors Junior and
senior to Berkeley and the programs also
include multiple workshops that convene
more short-term visitors
so this semester we have an extended
reunion of the satisfiability program
which happened a couple of years ago
alongside a full program on meta
complexity and there's a lot of synergy
and connections between these programs
and topics which is very exciting to see
every day here
and today I would like to welcome you to
the workshop associated with the reunion
on satisfiability and the workshop is
titled satisfiability Theory practice
and Beyond
first I would like to thank the
organizers of the workshop or put for
the work putting together an outstanding
program
and just acknowledge the organizers they
are Jacob Nordstrom who's here and to
whom I'll pass the mic shortly to say
more interesting stuff about the
workshop and Clarence mccrish kuldeep
Singh meal and Martina
thanks again for organizing
and I would like to just go over a few
logistics for the coming week food is
provided outside uh before the first
talk and food and coffee is provided
outside before the first talk and during
the breaks and for lunch you're on your
own but there are many excellent choices
to go within short walking distance and
uh we ask that you please leave any food
and drinks outside the auditorium so
that we can keep the auditorium uh clean
um and nice to use and if you need to
store your stuff for going out for lunch
or otherwise there are lockers in the
other side far side of the building
which you can use and our videographer
omelet far will be here to help with any
AV and other issues throughout the day
and uh I'm not sure is this a hybrid
Workshop or no it's my fish okay so
um okay I'll skip that point then but if
it is a hybrid Workshop there will be
somebody monitoring and you can ask
questions uh remotely as of course in
person here and finally last but not
least I would like to give a special
thank thanks to the events team who put
all this thing together so that's Ashley
Hassan Elizabeth Yuan for managing all
the logistics of not only what's
happening this week here but also
Arrangements uh to accommodate our
short-term visitors who are visiting
okay so thanks Ashley and Elizabeth
thank you
very much so with that I'll hand it over
Jacob to say to introduce the version
thanks and welcome
thanks
so I just want to start by saying that
it's great to see all of you here
finally
as as you know we tried to run this uh
program in 2021 but there was a pandemic
movement otherwise
and so now we're very grateful to the
Simons Institute of for getting the
chance to run this extended reunion at
least sort of a half of a program this
is fantastic and and this is what is
intended to be like the the main
Workshop of this set satisfiability
theory practice and Beyond program and
we hope
um the intention is that we really want
to collect
uh both theoretical and practical
research related to
satisfiability and and combinatorial
problems more in general
and so what we're hoping for I think if
you look back at the original program in
2021 was meant to celebrate uh 50 years
of MP completeness and I think NP has
had a pretty good run if you look back
over the last 50 years and and so one
way of viewing this Workshop as we're
Gathering here is to talk about look
back at some of the research that has
been done but also plan for the next 50
years you know what are we going to do
next and in particular uh we're hoping
for
um during the talks to see a lot of
focus on open problems on exciting new
research directions and also to discuss
possible uh connections between theory
and practice one of the
um I think
main reasons behind this program in the
first place is that different
communities have such a different view
of of South and other NP company
problems for at least you know for me as
a theoreticians the way I was taught to
think about npu it was like super scary
it's the you know it's it's a dead end
don't go there there's nothing we can do
and it was really like a a shock and a
very disturbing experience for me to
meet practitioners who were thinking
about NP as you know if they could
finally get it to NP then they were done
that's when they started writing their
papers because they knew how to solve NP
complete problems efficiently which I
was convinced was exponentially hard
um of course this is simplifying a
little bit but still uh it is true that
there's like a
very different views of these
um
NP complete problems NP hot problems and
Beyond on them from a theoretical point
of view we do believe that they're very
very hard at least in the worst case but
we don't know how to prove that I mean
that's one of the big open Millennium
Problems on the Practical side there are
amazing algorithms we'll hear it during
this week for for Boolean satisfiability
even for optimization problems such as
Max out constraint programming mixed
into linear programming but I think it's
fair to say we don't really have a good
scientific understanding of how these
algorithms can be so unreasonably good
and so these are
some of the problems that will
will be hoping to to talk about from
from different angles and and discuss
and not only during the presentations
we're hoping for lots and lots of of
questions and of course discussions
during lunch breaks during coffee breaks
um
Etc So the plan of the program
is basically that for the first two days
we're mixing uh
sort of fearing practice of Boolean
satisfiability in a more strict sense
talking about through the focus on proof
complexity and computational complexity
theory on one hand and on satisfiability
solving that's Monday uh Tuesday
uh on Wednesday we're moving on to
things like constraint programming
operations research
algebraic approaches uh Thursday has
more of a focus on how we can leverage
research on these types of problems for
questions like like formal verification
uh verified Computing and then Friday is
kind of the Beyond day where we pick up
a lot of different topics that are
inspired by but not strictly related to
so so again it's great to see so many of
you here and uh I think we can maybe
even get started
with our first talks our opening
speakers Alberto serious from from UPC
Barcelona who will tell us
where the heart problems are or maybe at
least about how he searches for them so
Albert without further Ado please the
floor is yours thank you very much
foreign
wants to come in
all right so yeah I want to talk about
the search of heart instances
now that's not searching for them in the
in any sense of computational sense but
rather in a mathematical sense so we
want to understand what are the hard
instances for algorithms and the
question is why do you want to do that
well my claim is that in fact this is
the only way or basically no way to
evaluate your algorithms and then try to
improve them if you don't know where
your algorithms fail and it's very hard
to know what you need to enhance your
algorithm with to improve it
so as many of you told me these recent
days and and Jacob mentioned it now the
2021 program was meant to celebrate 50
years of satisfiability of NP
completeness as Jacob said and this is
50 years of the paper by Steve Cook
which appeared in stock in 1971.
and there he proved that sat is NP
complete but his interest as you can see
from the title was on analyzing the
complexity of serum proven procedures
okay so the first few sentences of the
summary it is shown that any recognition
problem solved by polynomial time
bounded non-deterministic machine can be
reduced to the problem of determining
whether a given propositional formula is
a tautology and of course the negation
of that autology is uh
can satisfiable instead
satisfiability problem is the
complementary problem of
the topology problem and there is a
passage in the paper that is
particularly important and especially
this last sentence and so let me read it
to you so he says in the middle of the
paper he says that the field of
mechanical theorem proving badly needs a
basis for comparing and evaluating the
dozens of procedures which appear in the
literature
already then there was a bit of a mess
and it was not clear which techniques
were useful and which were not useful
and cook was asking for analyzing this
and making a theory out of it
he makes commentary about examples like
computer is a good Criterion so the
performance is a good Criterion but it's
not sufficient and then he goes ahead
and says that the theoretical complexity
Criterion is needed which will bring out
fundamental limitations and to just new
goals to pursue so in fact this very
last sentence to suggest new goals to
pursue is what I want to emphasize in
this book
you see that this sentence actually
falls in the second column of the paper
so I took it down here and in previous
talk that I gave I had to cut it down
here so bring out fundamental
limitations I had completed the world
myself but I think the sentence that
follows it is actually quite important
because when you find the hard instances
this is the fundamental limitations then
you have new goals to pursue which is
solve those hard distances
okay so complexity theory is today right
or proof complex
theoristic you have this CNF formula in
time Max format as you can see and you
want to tell it would be ideal if you
could tell oh I see this yeah sure this
is this takes uh
7900 foreclosures to refill in
resolution
that would be ideal right that's the
final goal we will be able to understand
sentences or uh see in a formulas at
this level
but this is just the Hopeless and now we
know why it's published we have specific
results
that explain why it is hard to find uh
the size of the shortest resolution
certification
it was not clear before and there are
many cases where you can find actually
very short resolution refutations when
they exist but in general this is a hard
problem
still we did quite a lot of progress
improved complexity trying to delineate
which CNF formulas are hard and which
are easy
so let me introduce now a little
selection this is an opening talk so
I'll be
staying at a high level so I'll explain
a little bit the selection of themes
improve complexity three themes and then
I'll go deeper into into one of them
these are by no means the only things
that have been not improved complexity
the first team is the theme of lower
bounds and upper bounds and I want to
emphasize the upper bound part
because lower bound is what you usually
we
end out as most difficult in proof
complexity but the upper bound part is
put and necessary for the program that
I'm putting forward
so here is an example it's this is
actually a theorem a theorem of hacking
which is the debris resolution
refutation of the pigeonhole principle
formulas phpn must be of exponential
size
this is a lower bound result this was
proved by hack in 1986 this is 15 years
after after Cooks paper and it actually
answers a question in books paper which
is give lower bounds to the DPL
procedure
um
this was known before but haken gives
stronger lower bounds to to the DPS
applying to general resolution as we'll
see let me see
now this is not only useful as answering
that question and as identifying one
hard instance but this hard instance is
actually quite common and it appears in
many contexts but for example it is used
to provide lower bounds in the Black Box
model of the Black Box query model for
total functions in NP classes the tfnp
classes so this has been used
when we want to show that several
problems of
total functions in NP are incompatible
one to the other then the kind of
techniques that are used to prove lower
bounds for the pinionable principle are
used to separate the classes
this has been quite insightful for
people in economics and in other areas
all right so so this is one instance of
this thing now
the other important aspect of this is
that this lower bound is actually tight
and we're after we're after type
bounce so we want tight up to the
constant in the exponent so up to a
polynomial Factor it stays because you
have also an upper bound of 2 to the
oven but it's also insightful because in
fact this we can see that this upper
bound cannot be pretty like so the
resolution refutation cannot be three
like because the three electrons
resolution computation the smallest is
bigger than this
it's one of the type n factorial like
totally M times
so this sort of tight uh upper bound
would also appear later in the talk
and this is one of the first thing so
I'm going to emphasize three themes the
one is the lower bounds and and upper
bounds and this is the first one
another thing that proof complexity
theorists have been looking at is that
of proof search or automatability
the problem is that you're given an
unsatisfiable formula and and the
question is you want to find the
resolution repetition and I'm focusing
on resolution for now later we'll talk
about mother proof systems
or at least you want to estimate the
resolution proof length of F and
remember this was the dream of the of
the proof complexity theory is this
you're given the CNF can you Can you
estimate the proof size before you even
start running your solver if the proof
size is too big then you might as well
do something else because it would take
too long if you're generating resolution
purpose
so it turns out that this problem is is
very hard and now we know this now we
know that it's both problems or both
instances of the same problem are empty
hard to solve even very approximately in
a way that matches algorithms that are
some exponential for the same problem
which was proved on me recently a few
years ago
a couple years before 2021 when the
program started
and there were some evidence that the
problem was hard but it didn't reach the
the point of entry hardness until 29th
so automatability is of course an
important question and this is another
thing that proof complexity theories
have been looking at
the first team that I'm emphasizing is
the application to analysis of
heuristics and this is an extremely
important area
and this is only one attempt to
contribute to this area of how do you
analyze keep it sticks
the algorithms that are written in
practice are
not always
not always proof guarantees for them
polynomial time guarantees or linear
time guarantees or anything like this so
you need to rely on heuristics
especially if your problems can be hard
as the problem of finding refutations
for example now we know so how do you
analyze the holistic which ones are
better than others and how do you
classify them and again here identifying
the hard instances for the heuristics is
one step forward I claim uh towards
trying to do this
so three ways you can analyze heuristics
for example through average case
complexity and that has interest no it's
interesting in its own right like the
erdog friendly random graph model or the
random model of CCNA formulas and these
are interesting for a special
by themselves and we'll get to them
actually we'll talk a lot about that on
Friday
and in fact approximation algorithms are
also
an area where the analysis of physics is
important
because after all an approximation
algorithm is a heuristic it's trying to
solve the problem exactly and the only
thing it does is that it finds an
approximation and then of course you
want to prove some guarantees of this
approximation and then what proof
complexity can offer here is hard
instances in the sense of Gap instances
so instances where the algorithm claims
some value and then you show that this
value is far from the actual optimal if
you're thinking of optimization
and then finally the analysis of
heuristics for branching and searching
within short spaces is this is of course
what we know in what we do inside
these are the three themes that I wanted
to emphasize
and and I said I will focus on
resolution
because well first day of the workshop
we want to talk today talk about Boolean
satisfiability but I'm going to be
comparing the proof system and
satisfiability with other proof systems
so but the language I want to keep it to
the language of satisfiability Clauses
that are very simple and because of the
satisfiability problem is the one that
we understand better from the point of
view of expressivity
in fact cook proved that satis and
pre-complete but it was in the air the
concept of completeness at the time in
1971. so in fact people working in
internal linear programming they were
also doing reductions between problems
and they were expressing their problems
in
programs or zero one linear programs and
it could have happened that someone else
proved that zero one industrial linear
programming is entry complete in the
same way that cooked it and then the
history would have been quite different
I believe right so who put the emphasis
in the logic
and by proving that satis might be
complete but if zero one industrial
linear programming had been proved then
be complete first maybe the theory would
have deviated towards uh
from which to express the problems
of course that's I mean that's still a
framework where things are done but here
we want to focus on the satisfiability
on the language of logic
given to Clauses with the clashing
literal you can resolve the literal out
and inference based proofs are what you
can see here is a sequence of groups one
after another and you have a left
premise and the right premise of the
resolution rule so this is the
resolvement of these two Clauses and
each one is either resolving of two
previous Clauses or one hypothesis for
your original form
and now we measure the proof
size and we have two flavors of size we
can measure the size is just the length
as it is here and this is what we call
dark size because we're imagining these
sequences a graph the graph given by the
edges the back edges pointing to the
previous uh hypothesis
but also Imagine This is requiring this
to be a tree and then you would measure
this as a three size so the size of the
proof is the size of the smallest of the
tree and then the three size of a
refutation of
three size complexity of a formula would
be the size of the smallest tree
and there are two other important
measures width and space with
particularly because there are tight
connections and interesting connections
between size and and
I'm sure this will appear later in the
workshop also
so as I said I want to focus on
satisfiability but I want to also
introduce the concept of algebraic
proofs because somehow we want to
compare and I want to find hard
instances for resolution that happen to
be easy for other kinds of proofs
because that's what I want to do I want
to do progress remember I want to
identify the hard instances to know uh
what do we need to shoot for
so let me introduce algebraic proofs and
then we'll get to that so algebraic
proofs are proved where now the
variables I mean you can think of them
and I was ranging over some ring because
you're gonna be talking about the ring
of polynomials rather than variables
these are now in determinate
and then you impose the Boolean Axiom
saying that well after all they are in
the ring but they are zero or one
so that's the Boolean actually impose
this and then you are imposed that they
are complementary x and x i Prime
introduced one variable for the negation
for its original one
and then closes become polynomial
equations like if at least one of these
must be true then this means that at
least one of these must be zero right
have closures representation represented
as polynomial equations and then the
inferences like the resolution rule or
any other inference you can imagine we
can't polynomial identities from a bunch
of polynomials you can compose them in
some way and get another polynomial
equation
these equations are satisfied then by
applying the identity you get another
question is satisfied and that one you
can add to your description
how is this identity actually
um
it's all right
so this is what I call some of monomials
proofs or some subsequence groups
this summer squares is a pretty standard
term right now sums of monomials is not
so standard it's what people call
shadowy Adams proofs
so I'm going to call them sums of
monomials because basically what you're
doing is is the following here so you're
having an identity polynomial identity
and this identity is supposed to be a
proof that your Formula F the equations
that represent the Clauses of your
formula
entail that P is non-negative
we know negative on all the Boolean
assignments because the axioms of the
Boolean assignments are always present
how are they present well because the
identity uses
these AIS are
causes of f or Clauses that are come
from the Boolean attributes so these are
your hypothesis and those ones you can
lift by some an arbitrary polynomial the
reason being that these are these
equations are actually equalities is
equal to zero equation so if this is
zero then whatever you multiply by it's
still zero
and then you add a
you can add depending on which system
you are in you can add either
chromiums which are just products of
variables and those are non-negative by
default and on top of it
you're writing uh
you're adding a non-negative coefficient
on front or you can add sums of squares
of other polynomials and those are
non-negative because we are not real so
anyway I didn't say that
these works over the ribs
so so squares of polynomials over the
reals or original negative therefore if
you compose the most positive
coefficients
then what you get in the end is
something that is productive to be
nominated
all right so this is your inference and
resolution can be put as an example of
this inference rule
and so now we're going to say that you
have
for example a contradiction how do you
prove a contradiction how do you prove
that something is unsatisfiable well you
derive minus one you have an identity
with the original axioms from the
formula you add some stuff to it and the
cancellations course here minus one
but this identity give you my U minus
one is a refutation of f
and we can measure the size and the
degree and the bit size and these are
the different kinds of measures of a
proof
for example degree will measure the
degree of all the components that you
see here
it's important that we're measure the
degree of the components because the
degree of everything could be much
smaller like for example the minus one
is right we want to say and you measure
the degree of the components that you're
using the lifts and the squares or the
monomials
column your size would come how many
monomials you have in total and that's
the measure of the representation of
this polynomial as an explicit sum of
polynomials
heat size is also an important one
because these coefficients in some
instances might be completely huge and
the proof infeasible
all right so these are
this is the algebraic proof system that
I want to focus on now the lovers of
polynomial calculus will say well there
is also this polynomial calculus proof
system I'm not talking about them about
it here but it also fits quite nicely
especially in this this light
or ring and then the polynomial calculus
derives new equations from all
and while these proof systems are
thought as a one identity so you have
one identity and the size is just how
many monomials you have
you could also iterate this but we're
not gonna do it now
what's the point of some of the
monomials in sum of squares products
well there are two points one point is
that it adds the power of counting to
the language of propositional logic
of course we're increasing the language
for reasoning
and the specification of the problem is
still processed that's how I want to
look at it I know I don't want to look
at for now as optimization problems I
want to want to look at the desiability
so but the the reasoning language should
be a bit stronger so for example
um now from the closest of the
pigeonhole principle which I didn't
introduced but I'm sure many of you know
you can derive you can derive anything
it's unsatisfiable but in particular we
can derive this that says that Muslim
pigeon sits in or h
and you can think of these variables as
saying that pigeon I sits in whole h
now if we look at this inequality it
says that the sum of the pigeons that
whole go to H the sum is over I is at
most one
so there is at most one pigeon sitting
whole age so here is the short SOS proof
this is what we want to derive this is
non-negative why is it non-negative well
because it's the sum of a square here it
is it doesn't matter doesn't matter
which one it is where plus Boolean
actions in this case multiplied by minus
one why not after all this is supposed
to be zero
and the whole exclusivity actions which
come from the PHP formula so this
actions say that you don't have two
pigeons different ones sitting on the
same hole these are basic actions from
the specification you can also leave
them by minus one they are supposed to
be zero and if you do this identity you
open up the parenthesis you get this
and say
now once you have this now you can
imagine that by adding all the proofs
for the different holes you will get
that the number of pigeons flying is at
most n but on the other hand we also
know from PHP that the number of
pigeons flying is at least 10 plus one
so you get the contradiction minus one
is bigger
oh
in other words the pigeonhole principle
has a very short and small degree to
refutation in some of squares groups
so that's a that's a powerful thing what
about some of monomials
well in that case the degree is not
small you for the visual holder but you
can at least show that the monomial size
is most so there is a monomial size
polynomial size monomial size proof
foreign
so so this language gives you more power
but one of the points
and again it's language for reasoning
not for specific specification of the
process
now another reason is that this area of
sum of squarespurofs and uh
it's Classics of combinatorics and of
different programming which are very
well studied in the mathematical
community and have very deep theory that
we could try to exploit
so for example admit to this classic of
a semi-definite programming sdp which is
the low bus data function and this is
the definition so the lowest data has
several alternative definitions
yeah I strongly recommend I see Donald
in the audience has a very nice paper
called the sandwich theorem which
summarizes the various different
definitions of
and how they are equivalent and
oh
the global data is based on the concept
of orthogonal representations so you
have this graph let's say the Pentagon
we have five edges and you want to
represent the geometrically somehow and
the way you do it is you take for every
vertex you assign a unit vector
and then what you wanted to find is a
configuration of these unit vectors in
such a way that non-edges get orthogonal
vectors
but this means you need to go to pretty
high dimension to be able to do that but
in principle is always possible by
taking large enough that image
so you go to high dimension and
represent your vertices as vectors that
are orthogonal or non-edges
and then you want to optimize some kind
of function subject to some of
normalization constraints and that's the
function that you want to optimize is
the one for the Lower State
okay so this function is either with
ready well no it's meant to capture
the purpose of the robust data which is
the one captured by
the sandwich theorem so the sandwich
serum says that if you take the Theta of
the complement of the graph this is
going to be sandwiched between
The Click number of G which is the
largest complete subgraph you can find
in G and the chromatic number of J which
is the smallest number of colors with
which you can color the vertices so that
there is no monochromatic Edge
so in some sense this is then giving
this is giving a sandwich or a
interpolant between these two very hard
to compute uh
quantities of a graph while the point is
that this is computable by semi definite
programming and therefore polynomial
time solvable
and there are solvers for semi-definite
programming you can hope to use them
now how does this connect to some of
squaresproofs well
it is observed in this paper Banks claim
that and more they do a lot more the
analyze is actually the the value of the
lovers data on random graphs and we'll
get to those in a second but one thing
they the way they motivate the study is
also by showing that in fact
the lovers data being bigger than Q
what does it mean well it means that the
chromatic number is bigger than Q so it
gives a lower bound on the chromatic
number that's quite hard because this is
a minimization parameter right saying
that it's bigger than Q it means that
there is no coloring with Cue colors
right so you're rolling out their
exponential set of things
so this corresponds exactly to
having degree to refutation of the CNF
formula they don't write it as CNF but
you see their equations and they are
basically the CNF formula that says that
the graph G is cue colorable
well in fact they're encoding of
colorability is basically the polynomial
translation of the CNF encoder the
standard one
which one is it I'll get to that in a
second
so there are these two good reasons or
interesting reasons to focus on
algebraic proofs one is that they add
expressive power to the reasoning and
second they connect to very well studied
areas in in mathematics in combinatorics
for now let me Focus because these two
appeared already in the sandwich theorem
so let me focus on this analysis of
heuristics and how we actually connect
to to some of squaresproofs
so we want to analyze
um and CNF encodings of the problem
whether G has a cake
and the CNF encoding of whether G is Q
cholerable let's see what we can say
about this this has been studied for
many years
study progress
and again the hope is that from this
analysis extract new ideas for Progress
like cook wanted to increase 1971 paper
let's start with the click problem
getting a graph and an integer does it
have a key click a complete subgraph of
size K very well so the problem in
computational complexity I'm not going
to read all these 10p complete carp 1972
proved it and then there's a long series
of things uh to emphasize that carp
himself
observed that this appears to be hard on
average for random graphs
their secret complexity lower bounds etc
etc
so I'm just out of curiosity is it okay
was that like an empirical term or was
it like a theoretical thing
um
they actually run experiments
speculating for other reasons he was
trying to think he was writing programs
he wasn't interested in average case
analysis
this is a very interesting test case
because if it's hard uh well I think the
most interesting outcome
we find some structure at least
all right so let me start with this uh
here's a common realistic that is used
by practical click solvers as I'm told
you you want to know whether a graph has
a k click or not then what you start
doing is you okay you greedily color
properly in the sense that without
monochromatic edges the vertices which
has few colors as you can
and if this happens to be K minus 1 then
you already know there is no K click
okay click is not okay
but of course usually you get something
like 5K or I don't know 100 colors or
some big number
and now the point is that now you can
branch on different color classes
because you know that well if these are
color classes then these are independent
sets so there are no edges here so if
there is a click it's going to have to
have one vertices in each in a different
color class right
and now you want you do some kind of
backtracking like uh branch and bound
when the current click size that you
have at this moment plus the number of
remaining colors is strictly smaller
than k then you know you cannot complete
that Branch to your backtrack okay
and of course many more complex more
complex characteristics are certainly
possible like instead of coloring with
that you put color with lower status
there are several heuristics you can
imagine but these are not analyzed so
far as far as I know
probably because it's too hard to
compute this or maybe because we don't
know how what to do out of it but we'll
see
how is the things encoded well you have
a propositional variable says that U is
the ith vertex of the click and then you
have Clauses saying that every
for every eye that is one element that
is the highest element of the click and
then for every known Edge you forbid
that I is U and J is V and because
just a standard encoding of the of the
formula
and the resolution proof complexity has
been studied but it's not settled
surprisingly
so first there is this obvious
observation that if you do the
exhaustive enumeration of K element
subsets
and of course you can refute the formula
in size at most n to the k
that's not very insightful because
that's the exhaustive search after all
so in this panel in this setting the the
target size that we should improve is
this n to the k
resolution
Maximo asked in 2013 they asked whether
you can prove lower bounds of this type
and to the Omega k for general
resolution and the motivation for this
is that
turns out that they observed that the
resolution can simulate many of their
practical algorithms and heuristics
and but also importantly for this target
of
understanding the hard instances is that
this requires seems to require new
techniques because the methods that we
had for proving lower bounds like for
the visual principle they don't apply
they don't work
and this turned out to be a very
interesting question
and there's been some progress so
themselves
in the same paper they they give lower
bound they said well for three like
resolution at least they can show n to
the Omega K lower bound
moreover it's not only a worst case
lower bound you can find this means that
you can find a graph or a sequence of
graphs for which this happens
but they showed that exactly on average
exactly at the threshold earlier the
threshold where clicks
uh start not appealing after this
and then the formula is actually hard
by the way if the click appears then the
formula is impossible to refute right
because it's satisfying
so so the interesting case is when there
are no Clicks in the graph
and in that case it's still hard to
refute
now is this a good thing well yes
because nowadays know this uh this is a
generator of hard instances so it's hard
instances for three luck resolution so
if you want to if your solver is
basically only dpll it's only three like
resolution then this is a test set of
very wide class of test cases where you
can try to improve your solver and test
it
well of course the question we ask
theories do we ask is what is it from
the random graph that is really needed
to prove to use the hard instances
because this way we can extract the the
difficulty and and focus on that and try
to improve your algorithms by by trying
to find or avoid that difficulty
so it is the structure of the lower
bounds proofs that work for random
instances typically not always like this
but this is the way that it's done in
this case
the first identify a property of the
graph and if the graph has this certain
property then you show that the formula
is hard
it's a lower bound
if G has the property then the three leg
resolution complexity is entity Omega k
and now you prove that with high
probability a random graph has this
property almost synthetically almost
surely
and the property in this case there are
several you can come out with but this
is one that actually appeared in other
contexts like in
the context in synthetic combinatorics
so this is called the rich extension
property which says that if you look at
any
constant fraction subset of vertices in
the graph in GNP with this B
then it has many common neighbors I mean
many means
almost
sublinear fraction but many
so this is called the extension property
when you have one common neighbor and
and the reach extension property means
that you have several by many
and the complete so the problem with
this property is that well nice it fits
this
therefore it becomes hard for Trader
resolution
but it turns out that this is satisfied
also for easy instances
so if you look at the complete K minus
one particle graph right they note it
like this so these are K minus one
classes where you have all edges between
different classes
now this is of course not doesn't have a
k click to no instance
but it turns out that uh three lakh
resolution does not know how to refute
the K click even though it's obviously
not doesn't have a k click and we know
very easily why it doesn't refute it yes
okay I'll explain so here you have K
minus one Parts the vertices the N
vertices are divided into K minus one
parts of equal size and then you put
edges between different parts
graph
all right so it turns out that the the
rich extension property is satisfied in
this graph therefore this graph is hard
for to direct resolution
so this property is not
[Music]
good enough to
it will not be good enough because it
turns out that on K minus one colorable
graphs
these are not hard instances for general
resolution
yes
to infinity or yes we imagine K is much
smaller than a yes okay
I I don't see how this is going to help
me when k equals 10 I say for example
10 or 15 purchases
I mean their asymptotics going on but
I'm not sure exactly
how things are going to include yeah you
can actually think of scale into
Infinity with the customers are quite
slow for this to make sense you know
like k or something like login
okay yeah
but it is one way of answering this
question and saying like you could
imagine like
you know cam resolution refute uh hey
click maybe in some conflict cubic time
or or enter the four or enter the five
and I guess this is sort of asking if
you have an end to the Omega K lower
bound then you're saying no that's not
the case
like there is
like as as you fix your pay click to be
some sufficiently large constant
then you won't be able to refute click
formulas for that constant ink say
whatever cubic or n to the four or enter
the five I don't know if that's
related to your question
yeah this is what uh
fixed cable blockchain and then
foreign
want to focus for algorithms that are of
the type fix polynomial in N so n Square
Times maybe a function that grows with K
badly maybe exponential but this will
appear now in a second it appears here
so if I may continue now it turns out
that the K minus one color of grass are
not hard instances for resolution they
are hard for three leg resolution
because they specify this extension
property but they are not hard for for
resolution and this was observed in the
original paper in that if it's if a
graph is K minus one colorable in
particular the complete graph
the complete K minus one particular
graph
then its resolution complexity is
polynomial with fixed polynomial
independent of K
while sure exponential in k
and the reason this happens is that uh
well there is a pigeonhole instance
inside
so you have only caymanas one colors
and this K-1 colors you want to fit a
click of size let's say classes are four
you want to fit the five click and then
you're gonna have two vertices sitting
in in the same color clasp and this you
can imagine as an instance of K pigeons
and K minus one meta holes so the meta
hole is the independent
now it's interesting to compare this
with the Lower State sandwich theorem
because that also provides a certificate
of uh not having a k click
because if the chromatic number is K
minus one the lower stata function is
also at most K minus 1 and therefore
that's an upper bound on the click
number
but this is not polynomial in both L and
K is the lowest data would be but at
least it it depends nicely on K so the K
doesn't appear in the exponent
and in some sense this is a better more
structure or at least
um
they're meant to be seen what's the how
these things compare so the certificate
provided by the lovers data remember sum
of squaresproof
um what is it what is the certificate of
the sum of course proof in this case is
it the position holding instance we
already saw that pigeonhole is refutable
in degree two but I haven't seen this
explicitly with my eyes in particular
in particular for the random graph
we'll get to that again
all right so so now there is let's go
beyond resolution three like resolution
we said the K minus one part instances
are easy for resolution so what can we
find as hard for the resolution
it turns out that we can prove lower
bonds for regular resolution but now it
has to be for the the random graph the K
minus one particle that doesn't work in
fact the question again we ask is what
from the random graph we use to produce
the hard instances and in this case the
complex the the property is not this K
Rich extension property but something
much more complex
so I can read it for you it says every K
Over C set of vertices has many common
neighbors and for every W of vertices
set of vertices for which every this
slightly smaller set has enough common
Neighbors in W there exist as smallish
set s such that every set that doesn't
have many common numbers in W intersects
Us in these many places
okay no hope that you will understand
not even I understand very well what
this is this saying
so is one photographs
okay
yes thank you so this doesn't apply here
so I decided to check doesn't apply
means
and we need to use something else than
the extension property because
and this doesn't hold for the camera
all right so but the question stays open
uh for general resolution so here are
the lessons we learned from click so
resolution complexity brings A New
Perspective into an interpolant of
between click number and and chromatic
number and it has it raises questions of
the type well we have an sdp Interpol
and this is the semi-definite
programming interpol on the lower stata
but this suggests that maybe there could
be another kind of interporeon based on
linear programming because the
pigeonhole principle is easy for some of
monomials proofs and in terms of size so
could there be that you can replace LP
size linear programming size the size of
a linear program that interpolates in
place of sdp that would be quite
interesting because sdp looks to be very
very geometric while linear programming
is a lot more combinatorial
for questions that are raised by this
research
now we have a new convoluted density
property of a random graph and it's open
to simplify it and we connect it to more
standard uh connectivity properties of
the graph like expander style coin
property does it Hide A New Concept that
we need to discover like the expander we
are discovered between back in the 80s
and for example we don't understand very
well this property is so much so that we
cannot produce explicit graphs
that have the property we don't know how
to do that while today we know how to
produce expander graphs we don't know
how to produce graphs and have this
strange property
now still open uh in fact
it's not even clear
to find worst case instances we don't
know of work is worst case instances for
general resolution and it's not even
clear whether the click density that
convoluted properties suffices already
these are the lessons and this is a work
so for the last
there are reductions assuming say eth
the public requires this much time right
so is there a way to plug through those
reductions to get something I've tried
this and
seeing how to do the reduction in
formalization
that's what video would need to do we
start with hard instance for in fact the
hard instance is counting the solutions
with the most K ones
foreign
all right let me now get to the coloring
problem
and the other problem is kind of dual
right the grab a graph will have an
integer Q you want to know whether you
can partition the vertices into Q
classes
uh without monochromatic edges so
without edges inside the class
classes are the products
by the way if you come from a more
practical side and coloring you don't
recognize well this is kind of like a
clustering problem you have a problem
you want to divide it you know the graph
can be divided into into Q clusters so
that every cluster is independent right
it doesn't have conflicts and to
minimize the number of
the model many clustering problems this
way
so computational complexity is again
very well studied it's quite important
that approximating the chromatic number
is a major open problem whether it can
be done efficiently which connects to
PCP theorem and unique conjecture and
many things that are going on today
and it also appears to be hard on
average but in a different sense so
that's actually what I want to talk
about here's the encoding it looks very
similar but it's not the same
voltage U is called I you say that every
vertex
fixed vertex U has one of Q colors but
every Edge uh four bits I mean you
cannot have the same color on both
endpoints
so the resolution complexity was studied
a lot back in 2005.
Mitchell and more where they showed that
they asked the question what is the
worst case average case resolution
complexity of the coloring formulas and
again their motivation was that the time
that the Resolution Group system seems
to be able to simulate many backtracking
algorithms let me give you one
backtracking algorithm that I find
beautiful
for coloring and this is called this is
the magnet calculus
so it's a calculus where you derive
non-q Colorado graphs and you want to
show that your graph is not cue
colorable so you derive it by this
procedure
here's what you do you start with
actions saying the complete graphs with
Q Plus One vertices are certainly not
cue colorable these are your axioms then
you have two inference rules
if you have already derived G as not q
colorable and H is a super super graph
of G and of course H is not qolitable so
you can derive it it's kind of a
weakening rule
the more interesting rule is uh this
splitting rule or
infinite rule that says that if you have
a non-edge in graph h
and you have shown that h plus this
an edge Within These two vertices
it's not too colorable
and the graph where these two vertices
have been identified is also not queue
colorable the NH itself is not Q product
so again this graph is the one you
obtain by adding an edge within memory
and this one is one you get by
Contracting the edge
now why is this sound
or because if if the graph is queue
colorable then the two colors of u and v
are either equal or different
if they are different then this one is
also Blue Collar one and if they are
equal then this one is also preparable
so that's why it sounds
so this beautiful calculus happens to be
complete you can derive or
cue color double graphs non-q colorable
graphs this way
and the size of the proof is defined as
the number of inference steps
and now these analysis they were
interested is the connection with the
resolution
if the non-cucular ability of a graph
can be established either three like my
diagram with proof tree like means that
you derive graphs in a three-like
fashion but rather like this until you
get your graph at the end
then the standard encoding
is refutable in small width because
width is logarithmic in the size and you
should think of Q as a constant like
three coloring you're looking at or five
coloring so this is constant times
logarithmic of the size so that's a
small width reduction so you go from
three like dire mid proofs to small with
refutations
the consequence is that if you prove a
width lower bound
for The Coloring formulas then you get a
lower bound and you understand the
macdynamic calculus
they go over ahead and they prove this
you take a random graph with a constant
number of uh
linear number of edges which is what
they get on average then the resolution
complexity has with high probability
linear width and therefore exponential
size
but not immediate with total Force
and the point is that this theorem you
prove it once for resolution and then
you apply it to many backtracking
algorithms with whatever heuristics they
use
now if you go beyond resolution what can
we say well this has also been studied
in particular the set of function of of
random graphs has been studied in fact
if you take a density
number of edges that is linear in N but
with a factor of Q Square Q squared
times M basically number of eight is on
average
then the chromatic number the the setter
function gives you a certificate of
non-q collability
remember
this is this is bigger than Q then the
chromatic number is also bigger than
cubed therefore you get the certificate
of non-collaribility
and by the result of kleinberg and
others we saw that this gives therefore
a degree tool so some of specification
of the standard encoding
and this happens at average degree Q
squared
and video
so what is the nature of these
certificates can we say something about
them
so here's the status and for random
colorability and how it compares to
random preset
so there is a threshold where after this
average degree which is the average
degree after this average degree the
formulas are not queue colorable
and this is very close to this 2q log Q
it's like minus log Q
then there is another threshold where
that's a threshold for the Theta
function we should be C complement G
complements sorry this was analyzed in
this climber paper
so
I think number after this is going to be
bigger than Q that's right yeah after
this you can certify
you can certify the chromatic number
require the Q by this as a function
now if you want to certify it by small
width then this goes already notice the
difference you should think of Q as a
constant well this is linear or
sub-linear but uh it's a function of n
in fact after this you get the threshold
for having a click of such queue
and after this it will be the trivial
problem because you already have Q Plus
One vertices all connected between
themselves between them
and notice here there is a nice
smooth transition on the width reaching
this thing
well this region is the important one
for me because here we have but it's
hard for width and for resolution size
but it's easy for to create some uh
so so this suggests that okay this is
hard to find but then
can we make our solvers working on
satisfiability be able to match this
thing so this is easy after all it's
doable
of course do you need to add this
capability to your server do you need to
just come up with the right heuristics
that would actually match this and turn
this easy also for your servers for
resolution it's hard but I mean the
heuristics will not work because they
always produce resolution but maybe some
pre-processing maybe something I think
closers that are not that are not
logical consequences whatever
so this is this is what the region I'm
interested in
other region happens to be hard also for
the data function okay so far we cannot
say much but of course if you manage to
match this not by using semi-definite
programming then who knows whether this
will go further right after all there is
no NP harness uh reason to believe that
that is hard I'm trying to post this
resolution with this so what do you get
for three coloring that's something like
up to at from constant Edge density all
the way to something like n to the one
over six so we're somewhere around their
concert yeah but then you probably want
W to be at least the square root 10 yeah
and to the Epsilon for example
so for a solution it's like hard all the
way from constant heart to mind the
polynomial intensity
okay okay
whereas SOS
can be the would even like constant
but not too large exactly
SOS can do constant average degree
when resolution requires good and
average
it's hard up to them
it will be easier
but at least it's hard up today
all right so this is the status and now
what do I have
let me just keep approximately therefore
yeah I think I'm running I'll watch 50
minutes talk so let me skip this
oh okay so let's finish with this
Challenge and in fact
should I go to half past okay we're
asking questions during reports okay
thank you I love this
I hope you find it interesting at this
you'll be fantastic
approximately
so now you have to eat the recipe and Q
number of stars and Q is important B uh
so you and now you're given a
pre-colorable graph of course you're not
given the pre-colorable and you're only
told that the graphics be colorable
you're required to find a q quality
you can be much larger so this is the
search version of the problem it's a
weaker it's an easier and principle
problem right you're given be colorable
graph Q could be 10 times p
that's all you need to produce 10 times
PA colony
uh this is a search version as a
decision version you put it as a promise
problem where you want to distinguish
between graphs that are pre-colorable or
graphs that are not even cue colorable
so there's this Gap you know problem is
that the graph has one of these
conditions it's either
few colors suffice or many colors are
needed so which one is the case
so that's the total decision version no
problem this problem is very well
studied but not so well understood
for example the three versus three color
abilities of course it's just three
color abilities and be complete but
already showing that three versus four
colorability is hard required the PCP
theorem it's quite difficult
yeah
it took many years and it took many
years to improve to the next one from
three versus
four to three versus five
so it's still NP complete but not only
requires the pcpc and it also requires
universal algebra techniques that are
not easy
this is the kind of techniques that
we're using the
satisfaction problem dichotomies here
now it turns out that it's open whether
three versus six is NP complete
it can be shown and be complete assuming
certain conjecture like related to the
unique games projector it's called the
D21 conjecture there's no clear
consensus whether this projector is
going to be true
but at least we have some way to
argue that all of this proving this is
going to
if we do this then we can do that
now it turns out that the best upper
bound
I mean this is the first that was found
in 1983 but the best one is not much
better than this so you can distinguish
three color graphs from graphs that are
not even colorable with the square root
of the number of vertices is colors
and this has been improve the the
exponent here has been improved down to
something like 0.5 in fact it's like
less than one five
so one one over five is not is not the
right constant
um but that's all I mean we don't know
three versus a constant arbitrarily
large we don't know whether it's hard it
could be polynomial time solvable
let me
explain victorson's algorithm
from the perspective of proof complexity
because
in fact maybe proof competitive has
something to say about it so
algorithm goes as follows it argues that
if the graph is three colorable
um
sorry if the graph
yeah if the graph is recolorable then it
finds a coloring with these many colors
so now what we're going to say is that
if a graph is not repeatable in width
three that's much weaker than being
three parallel if it's not it's a three
color ability is not repeatable in which
three then you can color it this way
and so here's the argument for this it's
quite similar to ignitions
so we want to argue that if the three
color ability is not repeatable with
three then we can color it with square
root of number of colors and it goes by
cases so either every vertex has low
degree and log means less than square
root of n
then it's already root and colorable by
Grizzly coloring because you have more
colors than the degree so you can do
greedily color of the thing you always
have an available color for the next
vertex
so let's focus on the case that we have
a vertex of large degree
well then what's the claim well the
point is that it will be enough to three
color the neighborhood
if we manage to three color the
neighborhood then we can remove this
neighborhood and Records using three
additional colors and each time we use
three new colors the point is that we
will repeat this at most how many times
Well square root of n times
and at the end so each time we use three
colors times square root of n times so
that's three times square root of n
and at the base case we use square root
of n total we use constant times
so it suffices then to show that the
neighborhood is recolorable
and why is the neighbor three color the
neighborhood three colorable
well if it were not recordable then the
neighborhood alone without the center
would not be too colorable because it
would color the neighborhood and then
put one more color in the middle
now if the neighborhood is not too
colorable then the coloring formula with
two colors is refutable in width two
and that's because it's a two set
formula and two set has with two
repetitions
but then from this formula to this
formula there is very this change but in
fact we're only adding one vertex so
basically we're only adding one closed
and therefore the width goes from two to
three
and therefore we have that this is
refutable in with three but if a sub
graph of the original graph is
repeatable in root 3 then the original
one is also repeatable
so that's the argument and that's that's
always that is and what is this is
pointing out is that
this case analysis in one of the cases
you don't need to assume three
colorability Gene of the same
consistency with respect to three
colorability
then we ask how far much further can we
do this
and well we didn't manage to get to end
to the Epsilon which would be quite nice
because remember one-fifth is the best
that is known in polynomial time but we
were able to do that in some non-trivial
sub-exponential time
so the width is sub-linear
and the corollary is this is that we can
do the three versus n to the Epsilon
coloring problem in some sub exponential
time and notice this doesn't look very
good but at least it's not strongly
exponential in the sense that
the exponent of the exponent right so
so this Improvement here is is
noticeable the reason naive algorithm of
one man reception we achieve this factor
of two this is the important one
and this is based in the case analysis
as in in Victor zone is a bit more
complicated
so in the distinguishing cases whether
some said has large neighborhood or not
and and then you in one case you look
over colorings and in the other you or
something
this one is actually independent cases
and this is where we use
assumption now in this case instead of
being too collaterable what you get is
an instant instance that is too list
coloring what does it mean means that
every vertex has only two available
colors but they don't have to be the
same all the time
and two list coloring is still refutable
in with two and that's why it works
okay so if you want to look at the
details they are all here in this light
we can pass the slides
right so let me now wrap up and finish
so
so it is a challenge
so as I said I want to find the hard
instances to make progress on improving
the algorithms that's the point
we don't know what is hard for an
algorithm how we're going to improve the
algorithm we can
rise but we know we want to know what is
that makes it hard and to to focus on
that for example and to be able to
compare and that's why I focus on this
region
as a as an example
so this region says that it's easy
for degree to SOS that is hard for width
so the point would be to match this
without using semi-definite programming
and I've given some evidence that this
is kind of maybe possible for example in
the click case we already gave this
evidence that there is a vision Hall
instance somewhere there and okay that
you can do with SOS but you can also do
without because we already know if we
find the patient hole we know we don't
satisfied
so so this is a possibility that is
tried to do the easy cases that now
exist
easy for another algorithm with an
improved resolution
resolution itself won't do it so the
challenge then is to do well you can do
these experiments and
yeah that the student Killian Rothman
doing this experiments like in Barcelona
so you can you can feed your algorithm
with either a random graph at the right
large density
for the right density and in fact we can
make this explicit because this
you know the the thresholds for the
Theta function are very well understood
so these 18 in fact it is over generous
they should be 15. so for three coloring
average degree 15 okay and large we
didn't try to large science
um you fit a random graph or a random
graph with a planted cue coloring we fit
this to the algorithm and the algorithm
should be able to distinguish one from
the other
we put the time out that's the point
and so but of course the current sat
solvers I mean the the ends that we
tried is completely solve the thing
so so we need to try much larger ends
and then should be difficult for
according to the theory it should be
difficult
set of instances and then the challenge
is to improve the solver to actually
give the right statistics distinguishing
one from the other
okay so I'll leave it here and I'll
thank you for your attention
[Applause]
you're using uh errors raining around
grass have people looked at quasi-random
graphs
uh well uh Ron Graham and fan come
at this Theory upon right
you you say that it has certain
statistics
it has the right number of sea floors
and this sort of thing yeah that's a
very good question
the
this is attended by this I'm trying to
identify the properties like having this
Rich extension property this is
but the specific question about whether
quasi random drives represents program
and others the answer is no
that kind
of there's room for theater
three in the approximate prep card for
four like you can't make the same kind
of consistency argument for all four
yeah no because the point is that two
two-sided specials
from four to three but then three is
that hot so already you're pushing to
like PCP land that's kind of the point
right because you said you don't already
so let's thank
you